quand tu fais quand tu fais des trucs
verticaux tu as intérêt à avoir le
soleil à midi hein dès que tu descends
non mais je parle là il y a plus
tellement de sauce il y a plus tellement
de jus
[Musique]
là attends tu es à 4 tu tu es à on est à
5600 tu vois c'est pour
ça quand tu vas descendre tu vas voir ça
va est-ce qu'il y a de vitesse pour la
boule à respecter non non c'est bon go
down passe
ok c'est quand tu vas aller descendre
très vite pour le il y a pas une vitesse
à descendre pour
la mais tu vas voir que tu c'est normal
à C là que tu es beaucoup moins de jus
hein
toute la merde ilenvoie en permanence
dans les BS de rétention çave
de
la sortie ce truc
[Applaudissements]
là tour là
j' voir j'ai l'impression qu'onme Jol
for
làb Ji en vertical
le préfér
c'est du camionis tu montes arrives
vers on descend dessus là ça va être
long ça ouais laisse tomber laisse
tomber lâche
lâche il pas de là pu su va jusqu'au
noir Mo je prendrai de là j'irai
jusqu'au bout du du truc tu vois je
suivrai dans le le
noir et je monterai je remonterai le
noir est assz prês mais-toi là fa
quegisse un petit
peu tu montes vers le
[Musique]
le
c'est trop
long long
60e imagines que là dou double
longueurach
trop pas la
forme c'est la forme noire du truc pas
du
tout c'est
ça super noir bout noir que c'est quand
tu arrives au bout tu vois que c'est du
goud Ron
[Applaudissements]
hein tu voir là ça devient noir au bout
de ça c'est noir comme l'encre qui vient
de tomber
là vient d'ammener là c'est ce vient de
tomber tout de suite là voilà au bout de
ça c'est noir noir noir voilà c'est comm
une maroire tu vois
[Applaudissements]
voilà bon c'est tout ce qu'on peut faire
on peut le faire peut-être qu'en
contrejour ça va être très beau ça
attends je re un truc quand
même je pense dans contrejour tu vas
voir tous les reflets qu'on on voulait
faire tout à l'heure tu sais ouais
regarde reste reste dans le noir al ça
commence à venir reste reste dans le
noir
je les vois déjà déjà ça commence à
[Applaudissements]
venir quoi que tu sois plus tu es où là
là je VO rien du tout moi noir
là tout
les ça devient toutes les voulez voir
tout à l'heure on les voit maintenant
voilà tous les reflets moi je vois rien
l'écran est tellement dans le
soleil c'est Mo fort que tout à l'heure
parce que c'est pas
cont ça va être beau là
voilà on va bien couler c'est
joli c'est super ça
non
ça brillé
[Applaudissements]
attention c'est super beau moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai on va le REP de de faudrait rester
ici et que je puisse travailler de là là
parce
que attends je non non non j'aime pas ça
il est pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pas c'est ça c'est vachement beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
çaop
[Rires]
[Musique]
est
je sais pas où tu
esage le
[Musique]
problème les couleurs
qu'
couleur en bas là c'est un vrai
[Applaudissements]
semblable une matière là mais c'est
inoui ça en dessous là pas pas dedans
incroyable regarde ou tu vois regarde
par la fenêtre regarde
la écoute regarde je où là ou pas on va
refaire
OK
regarde metiedans tu par
[Musique]
l'arrièreas les deux trucs bien fait
regarde
sublime la vach qu'est-ce que c'est be
ça on
est
[Applaudissements]
oh là là qu'est-ce que c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beau
c'est l'or c'est vraiment l'or du l'or
de la
[Applaudissements]
terre non non pas que tu montes tu
descendes
là je pense que j'ai
[Musique]
le dessus un peu
non
j've
passe dans le soleil là je
[Applaudissements]
pense ah qu'est-ce que c'est beau
ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas préféré lapin non
ouais on va le refaire ça c'est
vachement beau voilà ça c'est sublime ça
voilà voilà VO
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiensle tu descends doucement en bas VO
ah c'est super beau ça c'est magnifique
çaess de le tenir doucement c'est super
beau c'estarrive à le faire à l'arrière
mais pas par
l'avant tu pe
pas essaie de se
rapprocher
descendre un peu s' veut bien ouis mais
il a le
[Musique]
mec CIS qu'on pas le droit de
descendre j'ai le tirage dans les ah et
quand tu es sur l'écran tu es bon aussi
sur sur
les bouge làdans
là à fond on est beaucoup trop loin on
est de l'autre côté du
lac le problème c'est que arrive pas en
avant ok descends descends descends
descend
maintenant coup
regarde AR pas dessus en bas voilà voilà
metstoi voilà comme çaas D est
[Applaudissements]
dessus la matière comme c'est beau
regarde la matière c'est
sublime que c'est beau c'est
[Applaudissements]
ok là exa
perfect
si on le roule c'est pas possible pour
moi
[Applaudissements]
comment de pas pellicule làdessus parce
que c'est là où ça va être
beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pr plutôt derrière le tracteur qui est
dans le regarde par l'arrière le
tracteur il est dans la plate c'est
magnifique le tracteur est dans l'eau
bon j'ar ce plan là fa le tracteur tu
vois regarde ah il est sorti viens d'en
[Applaudissements]
sortir
des zoom sur le tracteur quand même on a
une dans l'eau là bon allez maintenant
on commence à voir les
[Applaudissements]
ronds tuas la matière là la matière
vachement belle en dous N
[Musique]
làff voilà zoom
dedans ah ça ça me suffit comme
brillance je dis ça ça me suffit comme
brillance audessus c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
trop
tu prends le celui qui est plus c de
l'autre côté c'est à côté à côté c'est
beau
[Musique]
tu as de la matière dedans tuas pas
là celui-là tu vois il a des il a des
espèces de V
ok tu ve tu
[Musique]
revenir
mon comme
[Musique]
c'est laoiteoite de ça
[Applaudissements]
douc
voilà ouvert mon av un peu
ouvert la band làdessus on va tourner
jeour tu vas voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non